At 850 milliliters taken off by long on Friday, four weeks before this, they took off
500 milliliters, little milliliters. Dr. says 15% of patients have a deba with Pekrae
Kibo pill. She left beyond it but is getting very uncomfortable.
She just can't keep the fluid under control, going to occupational and physical therapy, both
two times a week. I have lots of indigestion when taking supplements. This just started since
the radiation on my 11th rib, unless it is the adema in my body, any suggestions.
So the fluid in your lungs, I don't think, is from inflammation in your body. I think that's
the sighties from the cancer. You do want to monitor the amount of fluid production over time.
So the rate of fluid production. So if you're going in every four weeks and they're taking off
500 milliliters, then 850 milliliters, then the next time it's 1250 milliliters, that's a concern.
So that's a red flag that there's an increase in the production of sighties. Now there's other
ideas about this too. So some people will say, well that could happen if the cancer is dying off.
And certainly being out of Kibo pill, that could be a possibility. So you do want to measure
that side of the increase in fluid sighties with other signs and other symptoms as well,
just like, you know, judge anything by just one test. But if there's an increase in sighties,
then that is got to be a concern at least to be investigated. I've been taking them with warm water
supplements wise. Sometimes that helps. And other times it just doesn't matter. I suppose it could be
from the Kibo pill. Certainly that Kibo pill can cause nausea, can cause stomach upset. I don't know
what that Kibo pill does to your HCL production. So I would, first thing I would say is maybe
make sure you're taking your supplements with food and that you're taking some HCL or digest
type thing with HCL at it with that with that wheel to see if that helps too. Because if you have a
decrease in hydrochloric acid production in your stomach, anything getting into your stomach, especially
the capsule is going to irritate your stomach as you're not breaking that down quickly. So look at
the back as well.